it's something buyers now take for
granted new car models and new colors
with new features showing up in dealer
showrooms every year but it wasn't
always so in the new book glamour road
authors tom dole and jeff stork look at
how the auto industry found new ways to
appeal to both women in the 1950s and
young people in the 1960s by
transforming cars into far more than
just transportation barry peterson has
the story flowing lines of this car
prompted sophie's brilliant red file
gown which accents the glitter of the
new silver cadillac el camino
big fans meant big budgets for high
fashion with the chevrolet nomad station
wagon to sell car fashion the
copper-hued oldsmobile cutlass it
created an era of brochure and magazine
ads where buyers would hopefully swoon
over gowns and glamour why do you call
these cars
dresses of steel because they were
jeff stork and tom dahl wrote glamour
road about the fashion ads that made
cars so desirable
until the next year fashion has the
color palette of the season which
changes and automobiles have the color
palette of the season oh yes your car in
last year's color is tired look at this
wonderful new wood rose with a matching
interior it was fashion merchandising it
was just applied to objects made of
steel and it worked it worked it worked
beautifully
models posed with gowns by the likes of
christian dior and oleg cassini and
jewels by harry winston well there was a
particularly amongst the luxury brands
they wanted to connect their cars to
the finest in luxury goods so if you
could afford a cadillac in that era then
theoretically you're
traveling amongst the class of people
who can afford high-end design and d-or
gowns correct
and when a fur could cost more than the
car cadillac would test its interiors to
make sure new fabrics didn't rip the fur
off the coat it's a different time when
you think in the 50s the concept of
animal rights was making sure that the
car wouldn't hurt your fur coat right
and they did and they did
and if women needed help there was an ad
for that my favorite ad
how to change a tire if you're a woman
here's my advice put on some fresh
lipstick fluff up your hairdo stand in a
safe spot off the road wave and look
helpless and feminine if this doesn't do
the trick i guess i've overestimated men
especially truck drivers if passing
males don't come to the rescue try to
get to the nearest phone and call a
service station
in the 50s training films taught
salesmen to talk horsepower to men and
interiors to ladies and started showing
mrs carter our color and trim book did
you ever see a woman who wasn't
fascinated by a swatch of exceptionally
beautiful fabric
women customers inspired upgrades like
the power princess package
power steering automatic transmission
and power brakes for a tap from a single
high heel imperial made it a point that
the daintiest slipper could stop the big
imperial
but car companies run almost exclusively
by men
slowly figured out that women might
actually buy a car to do that they
basically had to learn how to
communicate with women and it sounds
crazy but chrysler actually produced a
pamphlet that taught male sales people
that women are people like everyone else
and what did the pamphlet help them do
or tell them to do it actually taught
them
specific words buzzwords that they
thought would resonate with the female
mind
words like line and glamour and
decorator and practical the power of
women buyers exploded in the 1960s fancy
furs were out bikinis and bucket seats
were in
and the appeal to women was anything but
subtle like six and the single girl as
in six cylinders get it
and for the first time ads featured
black customers in ebony a magazine
aimed at black leisure and lifestyle
studebaker advertised their lark in 1960
in a series of ads that actually had
black models very prominently in the ad
as the supposed consumers and users of
that car
the memories of big cars drenched in
chrome may have faded but do not think
the appeal has dimmed
[Music]
when kim zakowski laid eyes on a 1957
plymouth fury at a book signing for
glamour road she would have bought one
the glitz got her the first thing that i
say when i'm in here
is it's very elegant the touches of gold
the nice big steering wheel this it's
just glamorous
i like it so it worked
it worked inside you'll find this lady's
beauty vanity this luxury is standard
equipment on all the larks
it took decades for women and the ads to
go from just a pretty passenger to
driving her car she bought for herself
and that legacy of change lives on well
past the days of furs and finns
for cbs saturday morning barry peterson
palm springs california
wow
that was
so good that was so good
fluff your hair put on some lipstick and
if that doesn't work
look helpless
that's how you get a taxi too is what i
said yeah
amazing i just said to you though that's
how men buy cars now too though the look
like this look
yeah yeah that's how yeah no the look of
the car matters what's crazy is i think
of my parents growing up in the 60s and
70s like we're not that far remember
very from that area
but we're getting older yeah we are
we're not fluffing our hair in order to
get a car what